But we've been doing that, I've been
playing a lot of PlayStation and
watching a lot of films and catching up
on film history and and like I said
drinking a lot. I actually said this
weekend that I was gonna stop drinking
for a week. I was gonna have a week off and
then literally Monday morning I've got
my own prop Ryan Reynolds sent me a case
of gin oh this morning
no drinking the whole week I'm not
drinking it all and then literally the
doorbell rang and there was a
case of gin from lovely Ryan so I think
that's Deadpool trying to corrupt spider-man is
what's going on here. It says here on the
box it says some friendly neighborhood
spider gin love Ryan if I'm wrong
correct me but I believe you were
supposed to start shooting spider-man 3 in
July is that still the plan. I'm not too
sure. I'm not too sure. I was in
Berlin making a film called uncharted
with Mark Wahlberg and we were all ready
to go. We went to set for day one
shooting and then we got shut down and
we all got sent home so whether we shoot
that movie first or we shoot spider-man
first I'm unclear but I don't know.
But both movies are being made and
they're both really strong and the
scripts are fantastic so whatever
happens happens. But I'm ready to play
both I mean I played spider-man enough
now I could play him tomorrow so,
ready to go.
I'm speaking with Thor tomorrow and I
was wondering if you've been video
chatting with your fellow Avengers?
I spoke to Jake Gyllenhaal
the other day we were
chatting about doing a peloton class
together we've been trying to get on the
same bike and train together so I look
like a complete idiot. And then I actually
FaceTime Downey a couple days ago and he
was in the bath. Ah interesting huh how
romantic. But we've also been doing
these pub quizzes, these massive pub
quizzes. Where we've done one with the
Cherry crew, so the Russo brothers have
been involved.
Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is going to be my new
spider-man 3 marvel video as you can see
Tom Holland just went on Jimmy Kimmel to
make a couple announcements about the
movie talk about some funny moments with
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds in real life so
we'll break it all down big surprise
right after we get a whole bunch of
venom to
from Tom Hardy we get a bunch of Tom
Hollands spider-man 3 stuff if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Deadpool spider-man moment on
the video so just going down the list
starting with number 5 Sony just had Tom
Holland go on Kimmel to promote
spider-man 3 he's also got a couple
other movies that he just made that he
was promoting they just want to catch on
the synergy of all the venom 2 stuff
that's happening right now so Sony just
wants as much spider-man on people's
brains as possible right now the other
movie that he made with the Russo
brothers outside of the Marvel System
recently was a film called cheery I
don't know when that's coming out is
supposed to come out later this year but
he also made another movie that's
supposed to come out later this year
with Batman himself Robert Pattinson
called devil all the time that's why
he's got that Devil all the time banner
hanging behind him on his bookshelf I
saw some people confused by that like
what is this a reference to it's just
another indie movie that you'll probably
be able to watch by the end of the year
I think people just saw him in a
spider-man costume in the word devil
next to it in their brains automatically
jumped to spider-man 3 daredevil because
there been rumors about daredevil in
spider-man 3 I've already done a video
about that those are just rumors and if
it wasn't clear this is all happening
from inside his house he posts a ton of
stuff on his Instagram with his friends
inside his house they've all been on
lockdown together so number four you
probably recognized the spider-man suit
that he was wearing during this he's
surprising Jimmy Kimmel's son for his
birthday just for fun there were a
couple people in my feed that I think
were just confused wondering if this was
the Scarlet Spider suit but he's
actually wearing a version of the
homemade suit from spider-man homecoming
the one that we saw in the YouTube
videos during civil war and then he
actually wore it for real during
spider-man homecoming he's even wearing
the cloth mask over his face the only
thing that's missing from this is those
special goggles that he created before
Ironman gave him the stark tech suit
with the auto iris thing ability 3
probably the funniest part of this
interview is when he talks about Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool trolling him the week
that he was trying to get dry by sending
him a case of aviation gin for free with
the message some friendly neighborhood
spider gin
Reynolds was actually watching this
interview while it was happening on his
Instagram account posting Tom Holland
jokes like oh no how could I have known
that you were going to go dry although if
you ever started a gin brand you could
call it alcohol and if you're confused
about why Ryan Reynolds posts so much
about aviation gin is a real gin brand
that he bought about two years ago so
that's why he's been posting all those
parody commercials and clips sometimes
he even gets Hugh Jackman involved for a
bunch of Deadpool Wolverine jokes Ryan
Reynolds is a complete and total the
gins pretty great thought I'll have to
try it someday sorry man I didn't think
the truce was actually real I know
everyone wants to see some spider-man
Deadpool crossover in the actual MCU
movies I don't think that Marvel has any
big plans for that right now
definitely not in spider-man 3 or
Deadpool 3 now that Deadpool 3 is going to
be rated R but now that Marvel does have
control of all the Fox characters
including Deadpool
they're both under the same roof just
expect to see a lot more spider-man
Deadpool jokes when Ryan Reynolds starts
promoting Deadpool 3 the way that he
took all kinds of shots at Hugh Jackman
and Wolverine
even though Hugh Jackman himself has not
been in either of the Deadpool movies
they just did that Hugh Jackman joke at
the end of the first Deadpool movie they
could probably get away with a
spider-man joke like that in Deadpool 3
but Tom Holland and Ryan Reynolds are
friends in real life which helps a lot
for funny crossover stunts like this
number two the next big thing he was
saying about spider-man 3 in the
Uncharted movie is that originally this
year Tom Holland was filming the
Uncharted movie before he was filming
spider-man 3 if you weren't clear they
are doing an uncharted movie based on
the video game he is playing the main
character but here's the funny thing
they literally had to cancel filming the
Uncharted movie the second day of work
because of the virus they didn't even
make it two days on that movie now he's
just saying that Sony is trying to
decide which of those movies they're
going to film first and even though I'm
sure some of you are hardcore Uncharted
video game fans I think we can all agree
that financially spider-man 3 is a much
bigger priority for Sony spider-man far
from home earned over a billion dollars
last year for Sony it was the first
spider-man movie to make over a billion
dollars at the box office
spider-man 3 is supposed to be an even
bigger story and potentially earn even
more money so when he says he's not sure
how it's all going to happen later this
year it's not so much if they're going to
film the movie it's just a question of
when they start before all the virus
stuff originally their plan for
spider-man 3 was the exact same
production schedule as spider-man far
from home shoot the movie all summer
into October and then released the movie
July 2021 with the first big spider-man
3 trailer releasing sometime between the
end of this year in January next year
pretty much the exact same schedule is
when they dropped all the spider-man
trailers last year for far from home but
number one here's the crazy thing with
the whole venom 2 and Morbius of it all
because Sony originally had four
different spider-man movies scheduled to
come out next year there was a special
untitled mystery movie that was going to
come out October 2021 they've pushed
that into 2022 we still don't know what
it is it's probably a solo movie for
another spin-off character the Morbius
movie is coming out in March venom -
which we now know is let there be
carnage is coming out at the end of June
meaning venom - is coming out less than
a month before spider-man 3 which sounds
kind of crazy Tom Hardy posted this fan
art then quickly deleted it off of his
Instagram its venom chewing up
spider-man so clearly he's just having
fun excited for some venom spider-man
crossover in the future I know there are
all kinds of rumors about what the
cameos and post-credit scenes are for
Morbius venom tube and spider-man 3 so I
will do Easter eggs for those when we
actually get to see them but it's
obviously going to be a while I think worst
case scenario though with spider-man 3
is that they'll just have to wait a few
extra weeks to start filming it this
summer then they'll move the spider-man
3 release date till later in July July
is like Sony's golden window of box
office they earned a billion dollars for
spider-man far from home
you better believe that they want to
earn another billion dollars for
spider-man 3 hopefully by next July
there's some sort of vaccine for the
virus in the works and people feel safe
enough that it won't destroy box office
potential but for the most part you'll
start seeing movies coming out at the
end of this July early August like
Wonder Woman is coming out there
August this year so if we get any of the
big news about what's going on with the
Marvel movies or the Sony spider-man
movies of course I'll do update videos
but leave all your big questions and
predictions in the comments below and
everyone let me know what kind of
spider-man Deadpool crossover do you
actually want to see in the MCU when
they do something like that
right now I'm still working on a couple
of big videos including my next infinity
saga re-watch Easter eggs video that's
going to  be for the Thor movie that should
post in the next couple of days as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos
when I post them congratulations
Astro lover 95 here the giveaway winner
from my last big Venom video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details
everyone click here for my new venom 2
trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for that brand new Avengers
infinity Saga deleted scene of
spider-man thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!